[Música]
un nuevo día de campaña en la carrera
por la casa blanca- donald trump votará
hoy sábado en florida y el ex presidente
barack obama liderará un mitin político
en ese mismo estado para apoyar al
candidato de su partido el demócrata joe
biden entretanto nueva york' al de sus
colegios electorales para la votación
anticipada
tenemos análisis en esta emisión de
noticias
en chile los disturbios rompieron con el
silencio electoral los enfrentamientos
entre policías y manifestantes tuvieron
lugar en santiago a un día del
plebiscito constitucional en el que los
chilenos decidirán si de redacta o no
una nueva constitución que sustituya a
la heredada por la dictadura de augusto
pinochet y señalada como el origen de
las desigualdades en el país
países europeos avanzan hacia toques de
queda en un intento para evitar nuevos
confinamientos generales el viejo
continente enfrenta a su segunda ola de
contagios y los gobiernos se ven
obligados a tomar medidas para frenar la
expansión del virus entretanto el
presidente de polonia entre duda anunció
que dio positivo para la enfermedad
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se hablan con un
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu donde hoy se espera
que el presidente y candidato a la
reelección donald trump emita su voto en
el estado de florida mientras que el ex
presidente barack obama realizará un
mitin político en el mismo estado en
apoyo al candidato de su partido a la
presidencia
joe wright en entretanto los newyorkinos
pueden votar anticipadamente en 280
lugares de votación en todo el estado
desde hoy hasta el 20 desde hoy 24 de
octubre hasta el próximo primero de
noviembre más de 50 millones de
electores ya han votado anticipadamente
de acuerdo con este conteo realizado por
la universidad de florida de lo que
representa un poco más del 22 por ciento
de los electores la cifra supera el
total de los votos emitidos en forma
anticipada en 2016 que sumaron en ese
entonces 47 millones según el grupo de
monitoreo de esta universidad
para ampliar esta información saludo en
este momento a ernesto castañeda docente
e investigador social de american
university profesor gracias por estar
con nosotros buen día lo que va corrido
de la votación anticipada este año
supera ya por millones al total
registrado en 2016 que lecturas se le
puede dar a esta información ya que se
debe que más personas estén interesadas
en votar buenos dias raúl así es la
gente
ha acudido a las urnas hay mucho interés
en la votación de este año y esto se
puede ver con la votación anticipada que
como bien indicas es mucho mayor ya a la
que se dio en su totalidad en 2016 a
pesar de que todavía falta más de una
semana así que vamos a tener que entre
30 y 50 por ciento de los votantes van a
haber votado antes de la oficial de la
elección que es el martes 3 de noviembre
profesor los sondeos le dan la ventaja
el demócrata joe biden estas cifras a
favor de bailén se podrían interpretar
ya como una proyección para el día de
las elecciones
pues si las encuestas le dan el favor al
candidato va a ir en del partido
demócrata y sobre todo en estados claves
hay un margen de error sin embargo en
muchos de los estados el margen de
llegan de la ventaja que tiene bailén es
de más de 78 9% así que hay 17 confianza
de que estos conteos esos sondeos tiene
siete validez claro esto va a depender
de la gente que de hecho vaya a
hipótesis que no sabremos el resultado
final hasta el día de la elección pero
si él pinta bien para baile ahora cómo
quedan las denuncias que ha realizado el
presidente donald trump sobre el posible
fraude que se puede cometer en estas
votaciones por correo al parecer la
población si confía en esta modalidad de
voto
así es en eeuu hay mucha confianza en el
sistema de correo público la gente puede
votar por correo muy pocos de los de los
votos se pierden sin embargo ahora con
estas dudas que ha levantado trump mucha
gente se está presentando a votar
adelantadamente pero en persona para que
evitar
este posible retraso en el correo la
gente está votando con en los estados
que se pueden en persona profesor
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en france 24 feliz día por
primera vez en la historia de chile este
domingo los ciudadanos decidirán si
aprueban o no la redacción de una nueva
constitución que reemplazaría a la
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet sin un punto en común de
acuerdo varias manifestaciones se han
reportado en santiago y otras ciudades
desafiando el silencio electoral que
rige previo al plebiscito el informe de
sebastián espinoza
[Música]
a pesar del silencio electoral el ruido
en las calles de santiago cada vez toma
más fuerza a dos días del plebiscito
cientos de personas rodearon el palacio
de la moneda en medio de la pandemia del
coronavirus para hacerse escuchar
también el camino
pero
el domingo los chilenos votan para
aprobar o rechazar la redacción de una
nueva constitución redactada en 1980
bajo el régimen militar de augusto
pinochet
[Música]
pinochet de ganar el sí
los chilenos buscan redistribuir el
poder y los bienes públicos sería la
primera vez que la constitución se
redactaría por un grupo de personas
escogidas por votación popular el
plebiscito era una demanda de los
manifestantes del otoño de 2019 quienes
realizan protestas interrumpidas por la
crisis sanitaria
continuamos con información de nuestra
región en bolivia al tribunal supremo
electoral declaró alisarse como
presidente electo de ese país al
concluir el lento escrutinio de los
comicios del pasado domingo tras el
conteo del 100 por ciento de los
sufragios el delfín del exmandatario de
morales obtuvo el 55 punto 10 por ciento
de los votos frente al 28 punto 83 del
ex presidente centrista carlos meza
entretanto se conoció que morales
estaría en venezuela luego de que
saliera desde argentina por vía aérea
donde se encontraba exiliado
eeuu el país más afectado por la
pandemia de coronavirus en el mundo
rompió la barrera de los 80 mil
contagios en sólo 24 horas por primera
vez desde el inicio de la enfermedad el
incremento se da a menos de dos semanas
de estas elecciones presidenciales del 3
de noviembre y donde el virus se está
golpeando fuertemente en algunos estados
clave como ohio michigan carolina del
norte pensilvania y wisconsin la
preocupación de los expertos sanitarios
se centra en la amplia propagación de
esta enfermedad con las
hospitalizaciones en aumento en 38 de
los 50 estados del país
y es que los países europeos también
registran nuevos contagios porque hoy 19
a medida que el continente enfrenta una
segunda ola del virus francia se
convirtió en la segunda nación de la
unión europea en alcanzar el millón de
casos los toques de queda nocturnos se
extienden por varias ciudades del viejo
continente para evitar así un cierre
total que pueda volver a afectar
gravemente la economía andrés meza muñoz
tiene todos los detalles de estos tipos
shocks andrei duda da positivo por kobe
19 el presidente polaco es uno de los
pocos líderes mundiales confirmados con
el virus
polonia es uno de los países menos
golpeados en europa pero este viernes
registró un nuevo récord de contagios al
igual que varios de sus vecinos europeos
la segunda ola del brote se recrudece en
el continente con un récord de 42 mil
nuevos casos en 24 horas francia alcanzó
el millón de contagios después de españa
este fin de semana el parlamento
debatirá un proyecto de ley para
prorrogar el estado de urgencia
sanitaria que le permitiría al gobierno
de endurecer su dispositivo anti kobe
alemania por su parte llegó a los 10.000
fallecidos la organización mundial de la
salud instó a los líderes a tomar
medidas inmediatas para evitar más
muertes y colapsos en el sistema de
salud we are the critical yankee estamos
en una coyuntura crítica de esta
pandemia particularmente en el
hemisferio norte los próximos meses van
a ser muy duros y algunos países están
en un camino peligroso sham canalizaron
a danger strike en italia los casos se
han multiplicado por siete desde
principios de este mes
roma- entró este viernes en un toque de
queda nocturno al igual que nápoles pero
allí sus residentes salieron a las
calles para rechazar el confinamiento
los toques de queda se han convertido en
una opción para los países europeos con
el fin de frenar la propagación del
virus
todos han recurrido a medidas variadas
para evitar un cierre general que pueda
volver a golpear duramente la economía
vamos ahora a oriente medio como el
comienzo de una nueva era así calificó
el primer ministro de israel benjamin
netanyahu el acuerdo para normalizar las
relaciones de su país con su acné tanja
hütt agradeció el papel de eeuu en el
acuerdo y dijo que pronto las partes se
reunirán para discutir temas de
cooperación mientras tanto la decisión
provoca una serie de reacciones del
pueblo sudanés que pasan de la
indignación a una aceptación pragmática
décadas de hostilidad de repente a punto
de terminar en las calles de jartúm los
ciudadanos sudaneses expresaron
sentimientos mixtos sobre la
normalización de las relaciones con
israel algunos ven la decisión como una
necesidad práctica después de
movimientos similares de vecinos árabes
como baréin y emiratos árabes unidos- la
normalización se ha convertido en una
realidad inevitable es el interés de
nuestro país porque muchos países árabes
han normalizado sus relaciones e israel
se ha hecho presente en nuestra vida
pública y en la vida de todos los países
árabes
otros son aún más optimistas sobre el
regreso de sudán a la escena mundial
después de años de conflicto y
aislamiento bajo el mandato de omar
al-bashir apoyó la normalización de los
lazos con israel porque allana el camino
para las relaciones internacionales
especialmente con eeuu se espera que el
acuerdo negociado por eeuu para abrir la
cooperación económica y comercial con
israel se centre primero en la
agricultura
sudán busca que el acuerdo ayude a
aliviar una crisis económica cada vez
más profunda
tanto si normalizamos las relaciones con
israel como
israel debe beneficiar a sudán de alguna
manera en la agricultura por ejemplo
porque sé que israel es uno de los más
fuertes del mundo en el ámbito
tecnológico pero muchos en jartún siguen
oponiéndose a la idea y continúan
considerando a israel como un enemigo
del mundo árabe cualquier país que
normalicen las relaciones con israel no
encontrará más combinación y deshonra es
probable que una completa implementación
de las relaciones lleve algún tiempo ya
que sudán todavía está en proceso de
formar un gobierno civil después de la
caída de omar al-bashir el año pasado
marcos ros ford futbolista inglés del
manchester united se ha convertido en un
líder de la lucha contra la pobreza
infantil tras la negativa del parlamento
británico a prolongar el comedor escolar
gratuitos ford ha conseguido tejer una
comunidad de restaurantes para que
ningún niño se quede sin comer una lucha
que procede de sus orígenes humildes y
que está abanderado desde la llegada de
la pandemia informa lluís muñoz
partner long al primer ministro
británico boris johnson le ha salido un
opositor inesperado el miércoles la
cámara de los comunes rechazó una
iniciativa de los laboristas para que
los niños más necesitados tengan comedor
escolar gratuito desde navidad hasta
semanas santas una negativa que ha
contado con la oposición de marcus
wright ford futbolista inglés que
combina el liderazgo del manchester
united con la lucha por la dignidad de
la infancia
estoy seguro que muchos de los que
hablan de forma tan insensibles sobre el
problema es porque definitivamente nunca
han vivido algo así así que yo dedicaré
mis días con la esperanza de que
empecemos a ver mejoras en el futuro
para las personas que lo
tras recoger 300.000 firmas para exigir
al gobierno que extienda las becas
comedor ransford ha cambiado el 10 por
el mono de trabajo y está ayudando en
comedores benéficos él fue un estudiante
becado y no quiere que ningún niño se
quede sin comida por eso desde el
miércoles ha conseguido que cientos de
restaurantes ingleses suplan la falta de
acción del gobierno mientras rivales
como jürgen klopp entrenador del
liverpool se rinden a su labor programa
defensor fue un niño que creció en
circunstancias difíciles bendecido con
un talento sensacional y obviamente
nunca olvidó sus raíces ni de dónde
viene que tenga que hacer esto es un
poco vergonzoso pero también maravilloso
entonces espero que su madre esté
realmente orgullosa de él madres reid y
broadway su lucha inició con la llegada
de la pandemia y desde marzo consiguió
recaudar más de 26 millones de dólares
llegando a 3 millones de niños y como
hoy cada 24 octubre se conmemora el día
internacional contra el cambio climático
buscando informar concientizar y educar
mundial acerca de los graves efectos del
cambio climático del calentamiento
global al día de hoy en las diferentes
capas de la atmósfera terrestre hay un
exceso de gases y partículas que son
productos de la quema de los
combustibles que el ser humano emplea
para generar energía dichos gases entre
los que se destacan el co2 y los
derivados del nitrógeno atrapan el calor
en la troposfera agravando el efecto
invernadero natural y provocando un
calentamiento global mucho más rápido
les quiero recordar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para que siempre esté
conectado con nosotros estamos titulando
ya que eeuu superó los 80 mil contagios
de kobe 19 en las últimas 24 horas
también sin la presencia del ex
presidente o morales el más retoma el
poder en bolivia al ganar
luís arce como presidente de esa nación
en los comicios del domingo
hasta aquí el informativo continúa con
nosotros
[Música]